[Música]
me gustaría proponer os que por un
instante os imagináis cómo será vuestro
mundo en el año 2050 yo soy una persona
de san sebastián y san sebastián es una
ciudad visitada por gente de todo el
mundo es verdad que últimamente no
tenemos muchas visitas por la razón más
que evidente que todos conocéis y una
cosa que a mí me gusta mucho es sentarme
en un banco de mi ciudad y pararme a
observar
a observar la ciudad y sus gentes
si todo sigue igual en el año 2050 yo
puedo ser una persona más que jubilada
que se sienta en un banco de su ciudad
mi pregunta es que nos podemos encontrar
cada uno de nosotros si hacemos ese
ejercicio y alguien puede preguntar y
por qué el 2050 pues porque los
científicos nos están alertando de que
si seguimos el mismo ritmo de vida y
hábitos de vida que llegamos tenemos un
límite temporal máximo antes de que
nuestra sociedad colapse y sedes estaba
el infecto del planeta y según las
previsiones y lomos los modelos más
optimistas es el límite temporal es el
2050 esto básicamente es por dos
conceptos 1 porque vivimos en un planeta
que es sensible a nuestra manera de
vivir a nuestra manera de hacer nuestro
comportamiento impacta en el planeta y
en los habitantes inundaciones incendios
olas de calor pérdida de biodiversidad
son algunas de esas evidencias y segundo
porque vivimos en un planeta donde los
recursos son finitos no son infinitos y
a esto hay que sumarle el hecho
en nuestro modelo de vida es un modelo
denominado modelo lineal es decir
nosotros lo que hacemos es extraemos
materia prima la producimos cosas las
usamos las consumimos y las tiramos este
modelo no es sostenible en el tiempo ya
tenemos evidencias de cómo algunos de
esos recursos que son imprescindibles
para poder vivir para poder revolucionar
en definitiva para poder sobrevivir se
están agotando
vamos a profundizar un poco en estos dos
conceptos hemos dicho que nuestro
planeta es sensible a nuestra manera de
vivir nuestra economía se basa en el
consumo de combustibles fósiles que
emitimos usando ellos emitimos gases de
efecto invernadero que vamos calentando
poco a poco el planeta tenemos medir
mediciones que nos dicen que hemos
calentado el planeta más de un grado
centígrado y que si seguimos al mismo
ritmo de emisiones podemos calentarlo
incluso hasta dos grados centígrados de
aquí al 2050 este calentamiento nos
aboca a una catástrofe sin vuelta atrás
51 mil millones de toneladas son las que
emitimos al planeta todos los años
aproximadamente a nivel mundial podemos
decir que el 30 por ciento de esas
emisiones procede de nuestra manera de
fabricar las cosas el acero el cemento
como hacemos las cosas procesamos
manufacturamos alrededor del 27 por
ciento de nuestra manera de generar
energía y unos alrededor de un 16 por
ciento de nuestra manera de movernos de
transportarnos esto quiere decir que
acciones encaminadas hacia la descarga
de la industria hacia la generación y
distribución de la energía o hacia una
hacia una movilidad sostenible abordaría
el 75 por ciento del problema de las
emisiones por otro lado hemos dicho que
vivimos en un planeta donde los recursos
son finitos cada vez somos más personas
en este planeta según los últimos datos
de naciones unidas en el 2021 7 mil 730
millones de personas y se estima que
podemos ser para el 2050 alrededor de 10
mil millones de personas para que nos
hagamos a la idea esto es como decir que
en el 2050 vamos a vivir el doble de
personas de las que vivíamos por ejemplo
cuando nací yo es verdad que este
crecimiento no va a ser igual en todo el
mundo hay países sobre todo los que
donde la clase media todavía está por
desplegar donde se prevé que el
crecimiento sea mayor y esto es una
buenísima noticia porque de alguna
manera nos dice que la gente va a
empezar a vivir un poco mejor pero a mí
me genera mucha incertidumbre porque
digo y de dónde vamos a sacar recursos
para abastecer toda esa demanda porque
se supone que esa gente va a demandar
tecnología
energía y muchas cosas
y a esto hay que sumarle el hecho de
nuestra manera de vivir basada en el
modelo lineal que hemos comentado antes
que era extraer producir usar y tirar
con esto lo que estamos haciendo es
estamos llenando el planeta de basura
estamos contaminando todo cuando digo el
recursos hablo de todo tipo de recursos
agua energía estamos contaminando los
océanos
podríamos estar hablando aquí largo y
tendido por ejemplo de los últimos
trabajos de investigación que acaban de
publicarse donde nos han demostrado que
hay micro plástico en el agua de la
lluvia a mí me parece una cosa terrible
pero bueno yo por mi profesión y por mi
conocimiento me quiero centrar en unos
recursos muy específicos que son los
metales por lo críticos que son y por la
dependencia que vamos a tener de ellos
si realmente nos tomamos en serio el
tema de la transición la sostenibilidad
en el escenario más optimista hemos
dicho que nos quedan 29 años para
definir desarrollar e implementar
una transición energética industrial y
social que nos garantice que no llegamos
al colapso y que mantenemos un planeta
habitable y para esto necesitamos
metales metales denominados tecnológicos
y críticos tecnológicos porque porque
son los que nos van a permitir
desarrollar esas soluciones que hemos
dicho que necesitamos esas soluciones
hacia la energía limpia esas soluciones
hacia la movilidad sostenible metales
que nos van a permitir seguir
comunicándonos digitalizando nuestra
sociedad y nuestra industria y cuál es
el problema entonces bueno pues que no
hay suficientes yacimientos mineros para
extraer estos metales
y además nos vamos a encontrar con una
barrera geopolítica porque los pocos
yacimientos que hay además están
distribuidos en ciertos países vamos a
depender de países como china países de
sudamérica la república democrática del
congo y para que os hagáis a la idea en
el 68% del consumo mundial del cobalto
procede de la república democrática del
congo
algunos de estos países además destacan
por sus bajos niveles de desarrollo y
sus altos niveles de corrupción esto es
lo que nos hace pensar que estos metales
además de tecnológicos son críticos por
el potencial riesgo de abastecimiento
que vamos a tener
y cuáles son estos metales bueno pues
algunos de ellos nos conocemos todos
como el níquel el cromo el cobalto el
galio el indio el litio pero hay algunos
otros que son muy críticos y son de la
familia de los de las tierras raras
nosotros les llamamos nuestros metales
raritos y son el neodimio el disprosio
el samario y uno puede pensar bueno yo
en mi día a día la verdad que muchos
neodimio disprosio y samario no no
consumo no incluso uno se puede relajar
pensando esto es que este tema no va
conmigo pero la realidad es totalmente
diferente me atrevería a decir que todos
los que estamos hoy en esta sala
llevamos en nuestros bolsos y en
nuestros bolsillos muchos metales
críticos llevamos oro plata galio indio
jitish cobalto cromo níquel y un largo
etcétera
simple y llanamente por llevar un
teléfono móvil en el bolsillo
estamos hablando de una transición hacia
las renovables sin tener en cuenta que
para producir un aerogenerador de un
megavatio de potencia necesitamos
alrededor de una tonelada de imanes
permanentes que están hechos a su verde
a su vez de estos metales raritos el de
audouin yo
estamos hablando de electrificar el
parque móvil me da igual tierra amarró
aire sin tener en cuenta que un coche de
cero emisiones necesita alrededor de un
kilo de tierras raras para su motor o
más de 10 kilos de metales críticos para
su batería
entonces qué hacemos
este es el mensaje no este no es el
mensaje el mensaje es que tenemos una
misión como ciudadanos del 2021 y
nuestra misión es empezar la
transformación más grande que hemos
conocido jamás es una transformación
integral y además de manera urgente
porque la cuenta atrás de up ya ha
empezado la solución no es más que la
suma de muchas acciones todas ellas
encaminadas y alineadas hacia una
sostenibilidad hacia una reducción de
las emisiones al final hacia un modelo
circular tenemos que meter en la
ecuación conceptos como reducción de uso
reciclado remanufactura valorización es
un cambio de paradigma pero es un cambio
de paradigma que nos afecta a todos y
cada uno de nosotros como educadores
no podemos seguir educando en la
abundancia en el despilfarro en la
insolidaridad como consumidores
como ciudadanos tenemos que ser
prescriptores de las nuevas soluciones
verdes nuestra demanda es la que tiene
que tirar de esa fuerte del desarrollo
de esa oferta tenemos que ser activistas
como profesionales y aquí voy a dar un
paso adelante científicos tecnólogos e
ingenieros no puede haber ni uno solo de
nosotros que no integre en su
pensamiento el ecodiseño y que no se
haga preguntas como antes de desarrollar
algo antes de pensar en un concepto que
materiales voy a usar qué va a pasar con
ese componente cuando llega a su final
de vida se va a poder desensamblar se va
a poder reciclar como empresarios como
inversores nuevos modelos de negocio o
creación desde esa perspectiva de la
economía circular tenemos tecnologías
vamos a hacer las enzimas sean
competitivas y sobre todo gobernantes
policy makers desgravaciones fiscales
política público-privada inversiones en
líneas estratégicas necesitamos que sean
que sus pequeñas decisiones por el gran
impacto que tienen necesidad necesitamos
que empujarles a que a que a que hagan
lo que realmente consideramos que tienen
que hacer
su responsabilidad no hace falta que
miremos pero qué es lo que ha pasado en
uno de los países más ricos del mundo
por el mero hecho de cambiar de
presidente cómo ha cambiado radicalmente
en unos meses la política medioambiental
y todo esto porque es nuestra
responsabilidad dar la oportunidad a los
habitantes del 2050 que tengan un banco
en su ciudad en su pueblo y tengan algo
que observar este casco
[Aplausos]